let's give up your next comedian huh
thank you guys
good to be here my name is Hans I love
DC I love how some of your license
plates a taxation without representation
and then the other one say and taxation
without representation what are you guys
fighting over here
I love can we talk to that
representation how dare you try to take
away my rights I mean I think those came
second and one I mean you can't just say
taxation without representation because
then it just seems like you're all for
it you know that's like saying I'm
having a license plate that just says
slavery the most important part of that
sentence is no sleep just be all about
the ideas that got you into the
Revolutionary War
yeah I saw another license plate from
Maryland it says war of 1812 and it's
great that you're proud of a war but
it's happened so long ago that it's not
impressive to me it's like I'm not
impressed by any war where I can defeat
both armies with a trip to Home Depot
I guess I'm fertilizer blow them both is
honor president being be proud of like
Vietnam or something yeah I am a Asia
North American trip Chinese I'm from a
Province in China called South Korea
so in Japan province a lot of people
make fun of Asians because we eat dogs
which I understand can be a heretic
because in America dogs are treated like
family members but in Asia we treat our
family members like family members this
is really old tradition we have back
home where instead of buying an animal
we love our grandma she never was better
in Asia unless you're a baby girl always
we throw you in the river love being
Asian you know Asian women they act like
there's such hot [ __ ] but back home
we're throwing you guys away they stay
humble out there ladies
you don't impress me you just look like
us
Asian men Asian when we look the same I
can put on a wig it'd be a seven like it
look like Sandra oh it's not that hard
to [ __ ] white dudes okay you don't
oppress I can do that too if I wanted to
the perverts man those whites I used to
date a woman who is really into yoga and
choke sex I was like do you enjoy
breathing or not make up your mind you
millennial I am NOT a racist I mean I
hate people too I just get to know them
first
you hate people for their skin I hate
people for their souls let me know when
you get to my level I saw a dude reading
a book in Arabic at an airport which
kind of freaked me out but then I saw
the folded corner of the page I put the
book away and I was like oh thank god
he's got future plans the narrative
destruction is the beginning middle and
an end to that he's gonna want to finish
that book up
I was talking to this fella and it was
like dude I'm a drug addict and you
people just have no idea what it's like
to be a drug addict I was like I know if
only you drug addicts would write books
or movies or TV shows or paint paintings
or sing songs about your drug addiction
but we all know drug addicts always in
the corner at a party keep it to
themselves why don't you tell a long
boring story a drug addict the bookworms
honestly I mean I think drug addiction
is a disease like a mental illness and
you want to let someone with
tuberculosis sneeze on you so don't want
someone with a mental illness talk to
you they're contagious
they must be quarantined anyways I am a
severely depressed someone please help
me this is a cry for help
[Applause]